[Music]  Kate Middleton gives off major Princess  Diana vibe the Duchess kicked off day  two of a royal tour through Sweden and  Norway by taking a page straight out of  her late mother in law's style book he  or she is glowing in a red and white  houndstooth coat custom made by  Catherine Walker now flashback to this  photo of Diana circa December 1990 the  resemblance between their outfits is  striking and much like Kate Diana paired  her most skeino coat with sheer tights  and red heels William and Kate spent  Wednesday visiting Sweden's Karolinska  Institute with Princess Victoria and  Prince Daniel where they learned about  the country's pioneering work in the  field of mental health and children's  well-being of course Kate looks stylish  oh the while check out this gorgeous  Alexander McQueen dress she wore under  the houndstooth coat which perfectly  highlighted her growing baby bump  you